on a une année de m2 qui par le
positionnement du concours en bac + 5
est devenu beaucoup trop chargé ça
réduit le vivier les les étudiants au m2
il cumulent l'alternance les cours la
rédaction du mémoire il y en a beaucoup
qui démissionnent qui ne sont pas
titularisés donc on doit revoir la
formation des enseignants et notre
ambition je pense que ça rejoint la
philosophie ce que vous avez présenté
dans dans votre texte c'est de créer les
écoles normales du 21e siècle avec une
possibilité on a lancé une concertation
avec les organisations syndicale par
ailleurs je discute aussi avec ma
collègue Sylvie rotaillot évidemment
immédiatement concerné puisqu'elle est
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
avec une possibilité d'avoir un concours
positionné avant le bac + 5 compris des
bac + 3 et ensuite une entrée
progressive dans le métier qui permet de
garder le niveau master une partie des
recrutements qui pourrait être fait par
prérecrutement dès le niveau bac et
ensuite avec une une formation
extrêmement dense notamment sur les
fondamentaux et sur un certain nombre de
valeurs essentielles bref beaucoup de
possibilités et on en discute en ce
moment avec les organisations syndicales